hi everybody uh
i'm psyched to be here i'm i'm psyched
to talk about this uh
so let's see i'm adam wolfe and uh today
i'm gonna talk about
rebuilding facebook chat and actually
there's a big project going on to
rebuild all of facebook chat including
the back end
but i'm going to focus on the front end
and the javascript we wrote it seems
appropriate
and you may wonder why we felt like we
needed to rebuild facebook chat
um and you know the answer was that it
was pretty terrible
and i pulled something that i remembered
from about a year ago this was like a
blog post
uh announcing our new subscribe feature
so you could follow people on facebook
and the very first comment it was posted
a minute after this went up
says improve the chat system and there
are a thousand likes on that comment
so um and actually this is a problem for
us because uh
the complaints about chat just drowned
out our overall user feedback it was
like really hard to tell
when we had new bugs and stuff because
you know people are always complaining
about chat
and facebook chats i think it's somewhat
unique as a client-side application
because
it's embedded in this browse experience
you know facebook is still delivered
very much as like a page to page classic
web application so we can't afford to
like load a bunch of code and then go
back to the server to build up a bunch
of state
because you know we're going to get
paged out quickly
the other thing is that the scale of
facebook chat is enormous it's you know
at our peak it's hundreds of millions of
concurrent users so
every extra fetch to the back end means
extra latency and extra servers you know
more cost for us and a worse experience
um so you know i think it's kind of
funny we've been doing javascript and
web apps for like
for a while now and it's still not
obvious how you build a feature like
this you know
everyone like builds their own language
and their own servers for this and
everything
um so you know we kind of approached
this like not
not sure of how what we were going to do
to to fix this
um and uh before we go into like what we
did i want to show a little bit about
what facebook chat does are do people
here use facebook chat on the web
like some people do i yeah i figure this
is like more of a twitter crowd but
no worries uh i'll show you what it does
okay so here i have um my alter ego to
biko jones
his facebook page and uh i'm going to
start a chat with nan one of the
facebook contingent who's here and you
know the very first thing i want to show
is that
uh when one thing that we did is oh
thanks nan
um one thing that we did is uh let's try
that again
um when we uh
when we um merged
chat and messages um you know we used to
have two different products there was
this uh
there was this jewel at the top we call
this thing up here the messages jewel
and then we also have chat windows and
um we merged the back end for these
things because we felt like hey you're
talking to your friend you know in
either interface
they should be the same thing but we
didn't merge the front end of these
applications so
the juul was controlled by like one set
of client code and the
chat window was controlled by another
and uh they would get out of sync all
the time that was actually like the
dominant form of angry feedback
um so uh nan will you send me another
message
um so now you'll see uh that when nan
sends me another
thanks nan nan sends me another message
you see they appear in both interfaces
at the same time
um and so like fundamentally like this
is what we had to do you know we had to
introduce a model for
what chat was doing and make it more
than just like a
very simple app it used to be just
something that was all about the ui
a couple other features i want to show
here let me minimize this window and
maybe nan will send me one more message
i think he's out of prepared comments so
hopefully uh
he has to type something on his phone um
we'll wait for that to come in
okay there we go so now i have a new
message and i'm gonna actually reload
the page here before um
before i do and what you'll see now is
uh
what i wanted to point out about this is
that you know even though
people have messages when they come to
facebook
chat is not the most important feature
on facebook obviously it's the news feed
so
like half of our users don't engage with
chat at all in a given day um so we
can't afford to like load all the
messages when the page comes up
and what that means is that now when i
raise this chat window you'll see a
little tiny delay where we have to go
fetch the
uh the conversation before we can show
it
um and uh even though we've done that we
still haven't loaded all the data for
the model
like when we um go look at our list of
conversations you'll see
that has to get loaded in as well so we
very much have to emphasize
incremental loading um they did take
away my shaving cream
yes uh that's right nan um okay oh and
i'm getting uh
lots of messages here hi everybody
one last thing i want to show is that
there's a group chat feature here
and uh you know i this makes this much
more complicated so
um tobiko here is gonna add adam to this
chat
um and uh this is a new uh group
chat and maybe nan can add some people
too
and the thing i want to point out about
this is that you know nan can add people
who are his friends to this chat
that and these are people that tobiko
doesn't know so
he doesn't have information about these
participants and those need to be loaded
incrementally sort of as these messages
come in in sort of real time
um so uh oops i lost focus
there we go um so you know that's
actually something that we had to
contend with and i'm gonna show a little
bit of code that kind of
gives an example of how we dealt with
that okay so
back to uh presentation so um
you know we did this we did this rewrite
and i you know i think we can say it was
a success
uh you know one thing that we really got
to do is we really got to focus
on the technology and the quality we
didn't have a bunch of new features to
add it was pretty minor in that regard
so that was very helpful
we developed a new command line
javascript test framework as part of
this project
and it's been adopted across facebook
and now we're working to open source it
so i'll talk a little bit more about
that
um the whole project took six months
most of the time it was just for
uh engineers working on it um
so uh you know that it wasn't like a
gigantic project and what i'm showing
here is the graph of
user tickets now unfortunately at
facebook like each individual user
report
surfaces to us as like you know
thousands of users complaining about
things every day
but we can tell we're doing better when
those those thousands become hundreds
um and that's kind of what happened here
and it's gotten better since so
uh you can see that this was you know
really helped with the quality
there are other things we're doing too
um
but uh you know the very first thing
that that i want to talk about and the
most important thing
and like the the thing that i would sort
of suggest you remember from this talk
if you're going to remember one thing
is uh that we introduced modularity into
the facebook javascript code base
in order to deliver this feature and
that was like the single best thing we
did because like
if you uh even if you have a big
steaming pile
like if you have a steaming pile that's
like in little buckets
then you can fix them one at a time um
and so
that you know that's like the single
best thing that we did
um so when i joined facebook like a
little over two years ago
all of our javascript was effectively in
a global namespace
um so you know you just write like var
blah
equals blah you know and then and that
would just like kind of run whenever it
ran
you could you could give directives that
say like hey when you load this file you
also need to load these other files
but there's no guarantee about what
order that would happen so it made it
really
really complicated um and any
any javascript code could break any
other javascript code so it's like
really easy
to to cause a problem and then really
hard to figure out
uh who had done what and the other thing
was that like we had
this we have this stochastic packager
that actually takes data from production
and tries to do the most efficient job
it can like putting javascript files
together
so the packager would like change what
javascript would was delivered in what
bundle
and that would cause bugs even though no
code had changed that makes it really
hard to figure out what's going on
and the last thing that this leads to is
like just layers and layers of
initialization because you kind of like
it's really hard to know when
everything's ready you just everything
sends an init event you know and you
like end up depending on like 20 init
events
before you are ready to do anything um
so we fix that with you know common js
effectively so now at facebook when you
write a
file you can require resources
and then you know you just can export
something
this gets transformed into uh like
something like a define function along
the lines of require.js
we can actually pull in require.js
because you know it's kind of easier on
facebook to just do it over
unfortunately
often but um we're definitely inspired
by require.js
uh so you can see that now like the
contents of a given file get run inside
a function you get
um you know global namespace protection
all kinds of good stuff
and you get this like initialization
guarantee you know there's only one
module named foo
and uh you kind of know know when it's
ready now um
that ideally that would have been enough
but for our application it wasn't and
um the problem that we had was that most
dependency chains
in our app actually start on the server
so um
if you think about like uh i'm gonna
talk about that
chat tab window that appears at the
bottom of the screen and just like
imagine the control that renders that
right so in addition to all the data it
needs it needs a couple other things
like a
like a configuration from the server and
also the templates we actually deliver
from the server as well
um and you may wonder like why in a
client's head app we're delivering
templates from the server
um the best answer is that initializat
internationalization is really really
hard
um and we have a big legacy stack for
doing that on the server so
we internationalize a template on the
server and then deliver it to the client
there are other things that we do with
these templates that are also helpful
but then you're back to this multi-pass
initialization thing where you know you
have a
module called chat tab view but you
can't use it right away you know
requiring it is not enough
and instead you also and the other thing
that you have is like when you want to
deliver these resources
to the client you have this like gross
interconnect between php and javascript
where php in our case sorry
um where you have to like require this
module and call a method on it
um and you know this is a really hard
dependency to track like it's
effectively a string in php so if you
want to
refactor that method uh it's a pain also
if you want to share this config you
know you end up doing this like 50 times
so the way we fix this is we introduced
this idea of dynamic dependencies
where you can define modules on the
server
so you just sort of export like a bunch
of configuration as a
dictionary or um a template as even just
like a string
and then you can require these templates
now we don't use the require keyword
even though
to the client these things look the same
as regular modules we use required
dynamic because
you know the one thing about this
approach is that it is a little bit
fragile right like you can end up with a
client in a state where
it needs a module that uh the server
forgot to prepare for it so
by using required dynamic we can kind of
keep better track of
what the client needs in order to be
able to initialize
but you can freely mix require dynamic
statements with regular require
statements
and then go about your business um
so you know this worked really well and
as i said like if there's one thing that
made this project work it was the fact
that we could
put our chat code our new shiny chat
code in modules that would not be broken
by the rest of the
javascript at facebook um there's a
couple things i feel like we didn't
quite get right so you know if you go
down this road
there are things i would do differently
um the very first thing i would say is
i i really wish we hadn't allowed
circular dependencies
i know that's part of the common js spec
um and i'd be fine allowing it for
third-party code but in our code
you know it leads to all kinds of
problems it's really hard to reason
about these circular dependencies
and it's really hard to know uh when
you're looking at one module that
like it it's part of a circular
dependency chain
um the other thing about it is that like
any time you have something that can
execute an arbitrary
order you almost always end up with bugs
when that order switches for whatever
reason
um the other thing i wish we'd done like
while we were at it i wish we had
modularized
javascript code's access to the window
and the document in that window
because uh just being able to freely
refer to the window as a global
basically means that you can only have
one window in your context and i think
like the destiny of all javascript code
is to run
on the server and when you move this
code to the server you have to
contextify it you know you have to say
like
there's there's one vm sort of per
request um and then the last thing was
just dumb we and you know instead of
doing like straight common js where you
can give file names
we did this thing where you kind of like
name your file uh
using a comment and that was just like
it's unnecessary
garbage now in the system but overall
you know big success
okay
the other side of modularity i think is
unit testing and i'm presenting these
things as if they're different but i see
them as very much the same like
you can build a module system but you
don't know you actually have modules
unless you have
an expression for the seams between
these modules and that's what i see as
unit testing being about so you know i
feel like a lot of people feel like okay
we i know we need to do unit testing i i
know that really helped
um especially an environment like
facebook where you have hundreds of
engineers committing to the same code
base
but uh you know i think like one thing
that people don't talk about too much is
like
just the workflow benefit of unit
testing like
i think most developers i certainly
would rather interact with my console
and my keyboard
than with the browser and the mouse but
in order to make that really work you
need to make the unit testing really
fast so you know when we we had some
unit testing for javascript but
it was actually slower to run the unit
test than it was to reload the web page
and click on things so like
you know that's like the wrong set of
rewards there
um the other benefit of unit testing is
is this design benefit so
you know if you have a unit test like
you're forced to consider
what is this unit you know what are the
guarantees that it provides and and
what are the invariants um so in order
to like really
capture that design benefit you need to
set up your unit test system so that it
um by default it isolates modules you
know you're sort of encouraged to test
one thing at a time
i mean then the last thing and i think
this is like really common
understanding of what unit testing is
for is is the idea that like
it's a signpost you know if you come
back or someone else comes back and
wants to change something
like there's a big long list of like
well this is what it does now
you know if you're gonna change it you
need to like think about uh the current
spec but in order to make that read well
as a specification you need to make sure
your unit test framework is really
expressive
and to this end i think you need to make
your unit test framework hackable
you know you need to make it so that
like developers on the team think of
committing to the unit test framework
and the unit tests
as like just as important as committing
to the production code
and you know like hacking on unit test
stuff is fun because like
you know if you break it that's really
good um and and it's also like it's much
more abstract you know it only
runs uh in your dev environment
one thing unit testing i think is not
for is like as a wall
you know and so people new to unit
testing sort of say like well i can
write this unit test but that doesn't
prevent
you from like you know writing some
other module that mocks this interface
and does the wrong thing with it and
yeah
you know absolutely and you can write
integration tests if you're really
worried about that but
you know this is unit testing is about
other thoughtful developers coming along
and
like sincerely trying to do to do their
best to like keep things working you
know which i think most developers
that's what they want to do um so this
is what it looks like and you know
we we integrated um js dom
so that you can run browser code at the
console it works great you can see this
is like a trivial test it takes about
under two tenths of a second to run um i
still wish it were faster but we made
some trade-offs that i'll that i'll
describe now
so the test environment is written in
node.js and that alone gives us like a
lot of
speed benefits so you know before we
start we actually kind of have to scan
all the javascript files it's really
easy to do that in parallel in node so
that's great
we also had to integrate js dom and
contextify in order to support browser
code
and that slows us down you know and
again like i wish we didn't need
contextify that i think was a mistake we
made
for isolation we did a couple things one
is we made it so that the
each test runs in its own vm and that
prevents cascading failures because i
think like
if developers get used to the idea that
you know uh
unit test breakage doesn't necessarily
mean that something's broken they'll
start to ignore it
and then you know the tests rot really
quickly um the other thing that we did
as we made is
that by default you get a mock when you
require something
and this is actually inspired by felix
gusendorf who's i think he's here
he presented at nodeconf like over a
year ago
his microtest framework and you know
it's the idea of using require as a
theme to inject
test doubles um and it's great it works
really well
uh that was pretty awesome i'm looking
for that guy um
but uh you know i can talk a little more
about that um but i don't have a lot of
time
okay and then the last thing is you know
this hackability idea and
they're the best thing working for us is
node so at facebook we don't have
production systems that run node
but there are a lot of people who do
want to hack on nodes so the very fact
that it's all written in node is great
and then the other thing that we did is
instead of integrating with crappy old
legacy systems
we rewrote them you know even though it
was extra work it makes it so that like
all the code is shiny and new
you know when you go track down a
dependency chain like you're looking at
javascript code and not crazy legacy php
okay the last thing and this is like
kind of where it gets weird so
um come with me uh
you know we we sort of abandoned like
object-oriented programming for for this
or at least like
sort of the framework style mvc i mean i
want to talk yay
and i want to talk about uh you know why
why we did that
so uh here let's again we'll consider
that chat tab view that window
um and you know here's like a classic
mvc
constructor for that thing we're going
to take a a thread object
and a dom node and what we're going to
do is like attach our template for the
window
to that dom node and like let's just
think about what we need to do to fill
out
the top bar of that chat window that
needs to say like you know
adam nan and two others or whatever um
so you know when you start off and it's
like a sunny day and you know
it's the first file of your new project
you write something like this you say
oh yeah the thread has participants so
we'll just get those participants
and we'll like map over all the names of
the participants and use that to
generate the title
and you know this works this is great
toy program you like go show it to
the product manager he's all excited you
know keep going
so but then you realize that you know
you get sometimes you get a message and
you don't
have the data for the thread you need to
be able to talk about this thread
just as an id before you really know
what's in it
so um cross that out and replace it with
like
some a vented thing where you know the
the thread has a load event
that distinguishes between the case
where it's got data in it and it doesn't
and then you know you have to kind of
ring your hands a little bit about like
okay but what if it already loaded by
the time i get here you know what does
that mean
but you know there are answers to that
question so now you know you
sort of wait for this load event you
register your callback um and then you
get the participants for that thread
and that works for a little while until
you know you get to this group chat
feature where you realize that like
you may end up on a thread with
participants who you don't know about
yet and what are we gonna do about that
you know and this is where uh i you see
two approaches you know one is
um people try to like have this
invariant that we never have threads
that don't have participants
best case that leads to over fetching
right because like that means that every
time you find out about a thread you
have to re-fetch all the participants
um worst case is like you have a bug or
you you know you've
failed to capture this untracked
dependency and you get to the client and
you're
you're trying to do this render a thread
you're missing participant data and the
only thing you can do is error
you've got no you know you've got no way
out of that um
so you know probably the best thing to
do is to not do this and do the same
thing to
participants that we did the threads so
we wait for the load of the thread and
then
we have to wait for all the participants
to load and then we can finally render
the chat tab window
and you know by the time we get here
like this is no longer shiny and simple
it's
like now really complicated and you've
got this sort of spaghetti evented
system
um you've got like subtle ordering
dependencies like if participants load
before threads
that may kind of change the behavior
here it's not obvious
what's going to happen so um
you know there there are two things that
like i really don't like about this
style
i'll try to point them out quickly um
the first one is
uh you know let's just be okay with
constructors and initializers and like
look you know class keyword thank you
um but uh but you know we have two
uh different kinds of apis that don't
look different right like
the thread knows its id and you can
always call get id that's fine
but to call get participants you have to
wait for the load event
and like there's nothing obvious in the
api that says this you have to kind of
like read through the code or keep the
documentation up to date or whatever to
really know this
and new developers will come along and
you know it works sometimes so it's like
really confusing
um the other thing that oop really hurts
is testability right so like
consider our test for the participants
behaviors around threads
um what we're going to do is uh you know
we can make a new thread that's easy
uh but when we call get participants in
the context of a test it's like
unclear what we need to test here you
know like
we can do two things one thing one thing
we can do is we can
sort of return real participants from
this call in which case like
now we don't have a unit test we've got
an integration test of threads and
participants
or we can return mocked participants
from here in which case like
the mock for participants needs to be
really clear about like what
what is done by participants code and
what is done by thread code
so you know you've still bundled these
things together and pulling them apart
again is pretty hard
um and you know this makes me wonder
like why do we do this whole
object-oriented programming thing like
what
what got us here um and you know the
first
part the like the ones we're all
programmers you know the one thing i
think we're all good with
is abstraction right like you wouldn't
you wouldn't write code if you didn't
like abstraction
and i think that's you know that's
something we can keep so
in the chat code there are definitely
like function constructors and function
prototypes
they tend to be for like ui controls you
know like that menu
or just or the chat tab view things that
we're going to have a few of
but um but that's where i would say it
stops
you know like inheritance uh that
you know that's one where like even in
languages that are built around
inheritance like java
like the best directive there is to use
delegation rather than inheritance
because
you know it's just so brittle like once
you put something in an inheritance
tree then you can't get it from anywhere
else except subclasses and
you know no one really does a good job
of like designing for inheritance like
designing an api is hard and then
designing a class that can be inherited
is like
you know 10 times harder polymorphism is
another one where like
if you have a language that has first
class functions and callbacks
i just don't get why you'd have this
crazy contract that says like
by naming this function show i am
participating in the showable interface
you know which is like again this like
super untracked uh
dependency in javascript um when a
callback totally suffices there and is
much more flexible it means that
you can have sort of pieces of code that
don't really
that aren't expressed as objects but can
still connect to
components that are um and then the last
one this is the worst one
i don't even get why this was a benefit
in the first place like
data that is hidden is data that you
know is not serializable
uh so like you know when the browser
page unloads when the machine crashes
when you migrate data
this is the stuff that you lose um and
you know
in facebook chat what we found is that
like we had to externalize everything
you know
we have to account for multiple clients
marking things as read or opening chat
tabs or whatever it's going to be
so like all of our data ended up
externalized and we sort of now i think
of like application data
should always just be json-able data
like it should never be hidden in this
way
um okay so that's my little rant
what did we replace it with uh so you
know i
have to scare quote this because like we
used a functional style
um not strict functional at all and you
know there are places where we have
objects and you know it's it's
intermixed but like in general i would
say
you know modules are connected by
functions and not by events or named
interfaces
instead of like class instances so
instead of a thread instance
we use a singleton to represent like all
the threads
and then this last thing is the thing i
just talked about where like application
data is generally
sort of thought of as always
serializable
so let's go back and look at that chat
tab view example now and you know the
first thing you'll see is that like the
signature for this constructor is
different instead of getting past a
thread
object it gets past a thread id which is
just a string
and now to go get the data about that
thread
sorry first we're going to attach a
template that doesn't change we're going
to pick out the title just so that we
can close over that makes the code look
better
but then we want the data about that we
pass that id back to the thread
singleton
um and uh go and and pass a continuation
that will get handed the data for about
that thread once we have it and that
means that like
if we have it great you get called back
right away if we don't we can go back to
the server and get it for you
um so this continuation then gets the
thread metadata and we do the same trick
with participants
and you'll notice that thread and
participants are completely decoupled in
this case
um so you know this changes the api it
makes it
simpler right threads is just a
singleton and you can
obviously tell like what things support
direct return so like
you know let's say there's some trivial
id transformation that we can do on the
client
obviously you just pass in an id get
back the normalized id
but the get function here
takes a continuation so you know that
you have to pass that
along with your call uh for testability
it's like a similar thing
um where you know instead of uh being
bound to the participants data we can
use like a mock function here
um that we just made this like utility
knife function that can be called as a
constructor
uh or an instance method or raw function
that captures the calls and can also be
used
to inject return data um so here we just
pass
a mock function to this callback and
then we can poke it off you know do
various things with the mocks make sure
that
threads made an async request if we
expected to whatever that's going to be
and then when we want to verify the data
again it can be expressed in json so we
just have like this simple equality
check
to be able to talk about our
expectations there
you know i do want to at least build up
a straw man and tear it down about this
functional style so what are the
what are some of the things that i hear
objections to um
you know i think the most common ones
like this is too hard
you know like four layers of nested
callbacks is like it's too hard to
follow the code it's too hard to write
the code
and people usually talk about this as
like i get it but someone else
wouldn't um and you know i guess what i
would say is like yeah coding's hard you
know
that's that's just the way it goes buddy
uh you know
writing these apps are um like if they
weren't hard to build then everyone
would build them and you know
we'd be out of a job uh the uh
the other side of this is that it's like
hard to follow you know it's like kind
of
it can be like uh really and you know
this is related to the like super
indenti thing
um i guess what i would say is i think
it's clearer than the than the tangle of
events you get
in a lot of oop code and so i like it
better that way
um another thing you see is like there
are too many includes in these files and
it's true like at the bottom of our
dependency chains like i was looking at
chat tab view
to prepare for this presentation and at
this point uh
there are like 40 includes at the top of
that file
i guess the thing i would say is like at
least the dependencies are tracked
and not and not untracked the way they
are in that threads participants
example um and then the last one is like
this is legit like
you end up using bind a lot when you use
this style and that can be really
inefficient like if you bind at every
call site like
every time you call a method uh on
another
uh module and pass a callback if you
bind every time
that uses memory so you do have to watch
out for that one
i had hoped i'd have time for questions
but i don't you'll just have to find me
and i'd
love to talk about functional and oop or
chat or anything else
um but uh i guess here's what i have to
say
modularity that's the big win uh you
know that's what you absolutely need to
do
unit testing goes right with it i highly
recommend it and
vivla functional revolution thank you